[Music]
DC Titans just concluded its first
season with a hell of an ending the show
treated viewers to an amazing finale as
well as an extra scene after the credits
that introduced a familiar location and
two big characters into the universe
throughout this video I'll be breaking
down everything that you need to know
about the episode as well as its
post-credit scene there will of course
be heavy spoilers so if you don't want
to have the show's ending rune for you
and I highly suggest that you turn off
now but for everyone else
I'm definition and welcome to the
channel where I roon it so you don't
have to the finale of titans follows
Dick Grayson as he attempts to track
down and stop a Batman that has went
completely off the rails and began
killing his rogues gallery this is
because the Joker murdered Commissioner
Gordon and now it seems that Dick
Grayson is the only one who can stop the
Dark Knight from doing more damage
Grayson is recruited by Jason Todd and
heads off into Gotham which is turned
into a hellhole by the episodes end we
in fact learn that this had all been a
hallucination orchestrated by Trigon
throughout the dream
Trigon presents Grayson with several
opportunities to return to his happy and
blissful life or to delve further into
Gotham's underworld which is of course
what he does as Batman goes fully off
the deep end murdering his rogues
gallery entirely destroying all good
that was left within him dick kills him
in order to stop him from going any
further throughout the series dick had
constantly battled with his good and bad
side and his final plunge into darkness
is beautifully orchestrated by Trigon in
an attempt to send the character fully
off the deep end much in the same way
that Batman went in the final scene
Trigon explains that this has been his
end goal the entire time and with dick
now fully aware of what he is capable of
should he lose self-control we are left
with a cliffhanger that the hero may
have lived long enough to see himself
become the villain we are then treated
to a post-credits scene starts off with
a bang by introducing the city of
Metropolis into the show from here we
are taken to a lab that sees doctors
completely ripped apart and witnesses
seemingly naked man as he walks along we
get a glimpse of a Superman logo
is tattooed on his shoulder confirming
that this is in fact Superboy but the
big reveals don't stop there and
Superboy then tears the hinges off a dog
cage which is revealed to have Krypto
behind it
fans of the DC Universe will instantly
recognize the dog and it's clear that
going forward he will be a companion of
Superboy where they take the character
next is unknown as in the comics he
pretty much didn't kill or do anything
to harm people whereas this is clearly
taking a firm stance that he may be a
villain how it plays out remains to be
seen but he's definitely going to be a
tough adversary especially with Krypto
in hand against the Titans it was a
massive reveal that I couldn't believe
and I can't wait to see what the show
has in future for fans so what are your
thoughts on the Titans finale and the
series as a whole comment below and let
me know and if you enjoyed this video
then please like it and check out my
breakdown of this week's other big DC
release Aquaman which will be linked at
the end this is a channel for people who
are super into superheroes so if that's
the kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]